[Music]
there are a bunch of questions next to
or adjacent to general artificial
intelligence that have not gotten enough
alarm because in fact there's a crowding
out of mind chair I think that we don't
really appreciate how where the concept
of selection is in the machines and
creations that we make so in general I
have two cars in the driveway I don't
worry that if the moon is in the right
place in the sky and the mood is just
right that there'll be a third car at a
later point because in general I have to
go to a factory to get a new car I don't
have a reproductive system built into my
sedan now almost all of the other
physiological systems what are their
preps 11 have a mirror so my car has a
brain so it's got a neurological system
it's got a skeletal system and it's
steel but it lacks a reproductive system
so you can ask the question are humans
capable of making any machines that are
really self-replicating and the fact of
the matter is that it's very tough to do
with the atomic layer but there is a
command in many computer languages
called spawn and spawn can effectively
create daughter programs from a running
program now as soon as you have the
ability to reproduce you have the
possibility that systems of selective
pressures can act because the
abstraction of life will be just as
easily handled whether it's based in our
nucleotides and our AC T's and GS or
whether it's based in our bits and our
computer programs so one of the great
dangers is that we will end up doing is
creating artificial life while acting
allowing systems of selective pressures
to act on it and finding that we have
been involving computer programs that we
may have no easy ability to terminate
even if they're not fully intelligent
further if we look to natural selection
and sexual selection and the biological
world we find some very strange systems
plants or animals with no
mature brain to speak of effectively
outsmart species which do have a brain
by hijacking the victims the victim
species brain to serve the non thinking
species so for example I'm very partial
to the mirror orchid which is an orchid
whose bottom petal typically resembles
the female of a pollinator species and
because the male in that pollinator
species detects a sexual possibility the
flower does not need to give up costly
an energetic nectar in order to attract
the pollinator and so if the plant can
fool the pollinator to attempt to mate
with this pseudo female in the form of
its bottom petal it can effectively
reproduce without having to offer a
treat or a gift to the pollinator
but in fact parasitizes its energy now
how is it able to do this because if a
pollinator is fooled then that plant is
rewarded so the plant is actually using
the brain of the pollinator species
let's say a wasp or a bee to improve the
wax replica if you will which it uses to
seduce the males that which is being
fooled is the more neurologically
advanced of the two species and so what
I've talked about somewhat
controversially is what I call
artificial out intelligence where
instead of actually having an
artificially intelligent species you can
imagine a dumb computer program that
uses the reward through let's say
genetic algorithms and selection within
a computer framework to increasingly
parasitize using better and better lures
fully intelligent humans and in the case
of artificial intelligence I don't think
we're there yet but in the case of
artificial out telogen s--
I can't find anything that's missing
from the equation so we have
self-modifying code
you have Bitcoin so you could have a
reward structure with blockchain and
there's nothing that I see that keeps us
from creating now that is such a such a
strange and quixotic possibility now in
this framework I don't see an
existential risk so that my friend to
worry about machine intelligence being a
terminal invention for the human species
probably don't need to be worried but I
think that there's a lot of exotica
around artificial intelligence which
hasn't been explored and I think which
is much closer to fruition perhaps
that's good maybe it's a warning shot so
that we're going to find that we just as
we woke up to Bitcoin is digital gold we
may wake up to a precursor to artificial
general intelligence which alerts us to
the fact that we should probably be
devoting more energy into this
absolutely crazy sounding future problem
which no humans have ever encountered
[Music]